maman maman maman n'est pas m'aimer
licola moment tu entends très bien
moi c'est nicolas j'ai les meilleurs
combats du monde
je reviens soyez sages
bataille de bach
[Applaudissements]
ma vie elle est drôlement chouette mais
un jour tout a changé au chaud comme
papa est rentré du travail avec une
nouvelle terrible jusqu'au bout recul
voisins il a eu une promotion directe
oui tout ça va nous demander un peu
d'organisation un peu d'organisation le
déménagement qu'elle déménagement
impossible tu t'en vas aux
missions encore je pars tous mes copains
[Musique]
notez bien ces sacrés angoissant berra
j'étais jour où il partira on va tout ça
[Musique]
alors avec les copains on a décidé de
tout faire pour empêcher ce déménagement
jeu qu'on trouve un trésor
on va organiser une expédition commencé
qu'il dise animaux oui j'ai pris sa main
square et
l'oeil
et le bon monsieur du bon
les enfants allez mettez vous à oran de
partage ducation est un sport de combat
n'oubliez jamais ça
aller au combat
tu vois bien les enfants oui
[Musique]
clotaire
surnom louis xiv
lourd
le mot 14 peut-être